Hình y lễ ngày 3 mệt thằng tư đặc biệt của C-Bau Anh, đi trong nhà man tặng bằng người cho trẻ em phụng biệt giới.
Thay vì lựa trọn những điểm đến su lịch nổi tiếng, C-Bau Anh đã sành kỳ người lễ ngày 3 mệt thằng tư để đồng hành cùng hành trình ra nắng.
Chừng yêu thương, mang đến những thay đổi tiếp thục cho trẻ em nèo tại các xá bên dưới phía mắc.
Chong không khí cả nước uống về người lễ thống nhất, C-Bau Anh cùng 2 bụng bởi Express đã mang ra nắng,
Chừng yêu thương đến với các điểm chương khó khăn tại tình cao bằng và lặng sương.
Đây không chỉ là một chuyến cho qua đó còn là hành trình mang đến những thay đổi tiếp thục cho điểm chương vụ viên,
giúp các em nhỏ có thiên điều kiện học tập và sinh hoa tốt hơn.
Tại hai xá khút xá và tâm ra, tình làm xun, dự án đã tính hành lắp đặt hệ thống bằng người mừng nong tư trình và khu vui trời nhà bán.
Để các em có khu văn vui trời phòng phủ hơn và học tập tốt hơn.
Châu khi đó tại cao bằng, đoàn đã thành thành khu nhà ăn bán chú hàng trang và châu tạm máy lọc nước hiện đại,
hó phần tạo điều kiện sinh hoa xe, ăn toàn và tình thương cho hàng chấp học sinh dân tộc thiêu số.
Phải khắc xúc động nhất là khi bảo an cùng các em học sinh hoa tên quanh cả khúc tình quanh cả.
Dưới không dành uống vi của nữ dường biên cơ, các xí bảo an đã cùng hàng chăm thế cố giáo và các em học sinh hoa giọng trong bài cuốc cả.
Tình hát bằng vòng dưới bóng cử động sau vàng tục bài giữa biên thuy đã hư dệ lòng từ hào dân tộc xấu sắc.
Trên sẻ về dây phút này, nếu nghệ sĩ xúc động cho biết đây là lần hát cuốc cả đặc biệt nhất trong hàng chình vệ thật của tôi.
Không anh đàn dân xình khấu lộn lấy, chỉ có sự gần kết giữa tình người và lòng yêu nước, như lại mang đến một sức mạnh tình thần vô của lớn nào.
Sự lựa trọn dưới phố về bản của bảo an cùng chương trình ra nắng,
chuyển yêu thương so hai bốn bệnh express tổ chức trong diễn 3 mệt thằng tư đã làm toa thông việp tích cực về chết giệm xấu hội của dân nghiệp.
Những nộ cười của chế em phòng cao khi có nhà ăn nối, bằng tìm mối chính là mình trừng sỏng nhất cho những giả trị thích thực mà chương trình mặt lại.